باسم يوسف يودع جمهوره في سيدني بالدبكه
الفلسطينيه عمرو دياب يتضامن مع اطفال غزه
من دبي ليله دموع جديده في الرياض وهنا
الزاهد تعلن انفصالها اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع ترك باسم يوسف ذكرى لا تنسى لجمهور
عرض الستاند اب كوميدي الذي قدمه في سدني
مؤخرا بادائه الدبكه الفلسطينيه في ختام
العرض وطلب من دور تصويره وهو يرقص الدبكه
على انغام انا دم فلسطيني ونشرها على نطاق
واسع عبر منصات التواصل واعلن باسم عبر
حسابه الرسمي على انستغرام عن عروض
سيقدمها في البحرين وابو ظبي بعد
ايام وفي دبي اقام عمرو ضاب حفله الذي كان
قد اعلن عن تاجيله سابقا وتبرع بجزء من
عائداته لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر وذلك دعما
لحمله تراحم من اجل غزه التي تقدم
المساعدات لاطفال غزه
وعائلاتهم وعلى سيره العروض والفعاليات
المؤجله تضامنا مع الضحايا الفلسطينيين في
غزه كشف الناقد طارق الشناوي عبر صفحته
الشخصيه على فيسبوك عن التحضير بسريه
اقامه فعاليات الدوره السادسه من مهرجان
الجون السينمائي منتصف ديسمبر المقبل
كموعد مقترح بحسب الشناوي الذي قال ان
المظاهر الاحتفاليه ستختفي وستقدم تظاهره
للسينما الفلسطينيه وغالبا ستختصر فعاليات
المهر
الى نحو خمسه ايام بدلا من ثمانيه ولم
يصدر اي خبر او اعلام في هذا السياق عن
اداره المهرجان التي اعلنت تاجيل فعالياته
قبل شهر مراعاه للاحداث الماساويه في
غزه وفي السعوديه تستمر فعاليات موسم
الرياض ومن ابرزها الاسبوع الماضي عرض
بوست مالون الموسيقي وحفل الفنانين
اللبنانيين وائل كفوري
[تصفيق]
واليسا
وي
وبفكر انا بتمايل على الب والنسخه الثانيه
من ليله الدموع وكانت مفاجاتها اصاله
ووائل جسار الذي تعرض في مايو الماضي
لوعكه صحيه دفعته للاعتذار عن ليله روائع
الموجي قبيل انطلاقه الحفل تسي ليه بالله
عليك وانا قلبي حياه روح
في وكان خبر انفصال الفنان المص هنا
الزاهد عن زوجها الفنان احمد فهمي من اكثر
الاخبار الفنيه تفاعلا وتداولا على منصات
التواصل الاسبوع الماضي هنا اعلنت الخبر
من خلال قصه نشرتها عبر حسابها الرسمي على
انستغرام وكان فيلم مستر اكس احدث الاعمال
الفنيه التي جمعت بينهما عارفه ان كريم
فهمي ده بقى اخو عارفاه وعارفه اخوه
وعارفه امه وزهقانه منه اخيرا توجت شينيز
بلاسيوس من نيكارجوا بلقب ملكه جمال الكون
لعام
2023 في مسابقه ملكه الجمال السنويه التي
اقيمت مؤخرا بعاصمه السلفادور سان سلفادور
وحصلت انتونيا بورسيد من تايلاند على
المركز الثاني
كوصفه